hello everyone welcome back to san diego
comic con for another little demon
interview i have the voice cast with me
right now
congratulations i've seen one episode
your show is wild and it's very much my
speed oh great thank you i mean
yeah so for each of you now to highlight
your characters we've obviously seen
demon hunters satan and the antichrist
on screen before can you give us some
defining qualities that make your
versions of those characters stand out
from anything we've seen before well um
you you guys go first ladies first well
i'll start with my character chrissy who
is um
a 13 year old girl and i think that like
that's a really exciting um way to
to view satan or the antichrist and
um she's actually like wants to be very
normal and just uh you know live her
life uh as a normal
teen kid um but is you know
cursed with um
the blood of satan um and uh has to uh
grapple with that so it's um it's kind
of it's a really fun new depiction
i think of of that thus far can confirm
yes all right aubry how about you um yes
i play laura feinberg she's a single
mother
i don't think we've ever seen a single
mom
fighting demons
um and trying to get her laundry done
and take care of her daughter all by
herself
at the same time
and i like laura because she's a flawed
character you know she had sex with
satan a couple years ago she couldn't
resist
um she can't help it she's got really
bad taste in men
um
but uh she's just trying to keep it
together you know
and uh she's doing the best she can
and i just think it's good to see a
woman like that you know in this day and
age
um just doing the best she can she kicks
so much ass and i love it
yeah she does she does i know how to
pick them you know
satan is like very very uh usually uh
portrayed in many many ways he's got
many many faces and i feel like
a lot of times he's been maligned i mean
he's really a nice guy deep down inside
he's really a good guy i mean he does
create havoc and he does but i did i did
choose the right woman to have
my baby with and
even though it turned out that she hid
the baby from me for 13 years
i knew that i would one day be united
with my
son
that's the thing
there's the rub
it turns out it's a girl the man you
know and so
it's really
it's it's very so the first obstacle for
me to
the hurdle is
to jump over is the fact that
she's a woman a female she's a young
woman and i know that
the future is female and so i embrace
that with all my heart now
i did pick a very formidable opponent i
didn't know she was going to be an
opponent my laura but uh she turned out
to be very very crafty and was very
successful and they met their match
keeping me from my daughter but
things change time goes on and and
satan will rule
and uh and uh and be uh sounds like a
challenge uh he will be uh victorious
i can't wait to see how all of that pans
out
so aubry for you i know you've
collaborated with the creators on little
demon before correct me if i'm wrong on
any of this but i believe you guys
worked on a series and then it didn't
take off what happens after that happens
do you say to each other we want to keep
collaborating and we're going to wait
for the right thing to spark yeah well
you know the i've known these guys uh
since i was a teenager in fact i've
known seth kirscher since i was 12 years
old how did you two meet we met at
community theater
in wilmington delaware uh which is where
our show takes place in delaware
middletown delaware um and i've known uh
darcy and kieran since i was 18 19 years
old so we we all came up in new york
together we were on a sketch group
together and did all kinds of stuff we
did some live-action stuff and you know
they didn't understand us we're ahead of
our time
so um we needed animation to kind of you
know bring us to our full potential
um and now here we are did you always
know you wanted to work on this ever
since they first told you about it oh
yeah for sure yeah i mean they they
developed the characters really for me
and lucy and danny like it was a it was
a real team effort so that means that
they didn't have to do any convincing
there so did you two know them at all
before this project came along as well
yeah lucy lucy i met darcy doing theater
in new york and uh
i was in one of her plays and then
through her i met seth and kieran and
then aubry and introduced them to danny
and my brother jake and you know we all
uh
the thing is about it is that like it is
like uh
a family that we are we've created and
you know it's dysfunctional but like you
know that's what it is and that's what
we're portraying on the screen as well
so um you know we we love each other on
and off the
screen so i love it a lot goes into
these things yeah it does from the first
time uh uh lucy and uh aubry um aubry uh
plaza
darcy told me the idea this was i'm
sorry
i'm sorry
um from the first time i heard the idea
i
i thought it was like really a terrific
space to you know explore and then you
know we had never done any animation or
anything like that and uh then when we
were introduced to uh dan harmon and his
uh crew
that was really a plus because you know
they embraced us and they brought us
along and uh they've really been uh
inspirational in a lot of ways getting
us uh keeping us up above because
animation is very very difficult it's a
different beast and
it's been a real wonderful experience
working with them danny you've voiced
some characters in the past but never a
lead character on a series right no
never
no not in a in an animated i did the
lorax and a couple of things in philip
tatis and hercules and things but this
is like really a special uh this is
really an interesting uh a concept
because idea way working there everybody
is involved we we get to do when we were
in the pandemic we had to do it by zoom
but aubry was there and lucy was there
and i that all the characters were like
on the little you know we do as much as
we could on the squares we're hoping
that next year we'll be able to be
together more and actually sit there and
look at each other and
talk you know and do the characters so
even though you were on zoom you were
able to record your work together yeah
yeah we did we did a lot of
joint sessions yeah it's good to
improvise you know get into it do the
scenes what is it like improvising for
an animated series do you have some
material that's already been created for
you to look at and then it's just you're
allowed to we're we're gone
i feel like this is setting the scene a
little bit oh wow
chaos begins
danny are you doing this is upon us okay
i'll settle it down
okay now we can go okay thank you danny
but seriously it just worked
the scripts are all written by uh darcy
seth and kieran and then we are given
those as you know we say their lines but
then
um we do fun runs
where we're able to just you know
riff a bit and you know play the scene
in a different way and you know improv
some things and a lot of each other a
lot of
a lot of talking over each other
and that makes it um you know
that's made it really exciting and i
think like brought out a lot of the like
subtleties and the characters as well
lucy is this your first time voicing an
animated character yeah yeah even with
your past acting experience is there
anything about what it takes to voice an
animated character that required like a
little adjusting or maybe a new
technique that you've never used yeah of
course i mean i it was what's really
been interesting is like being able to
um try it out and then hear what it is
and then
because i'm rip a producer also i get
that luxury of like
you know sculpting it a bit and um
you know i think it's like amazing what
actors can do with their voices i i take
my hats off to all animated animator
actor voice actors everywhere because
it's it's actually very difficult and
very even though you're just in a booth
and not in costume or you know whatever
on camera it's the
the mic picks up everything and you can
get
so many nuances um in the voice and the
performance and um it's like it's just
so fun once you know once you get into
it i'm like i'm totally hooked i love it
i want to tease more of the show so
badly we don't have very much time
though so my last question for all three
of you will be can you pick one element
or one non-spoilery thing that happens
on the show that makes you say to
yourself i cannot believe x fx actually
allowed us to do this
well
fx is uh after all f x x is after all
fearless that's right so they are with
us and we will push the envelope until
we are corralled in
and and sat on but we uh i think my one
of my uh uh
big ones is uh
you know
the fact that uh you know satan is uh
you know is very bold in terms of who he
murders he murders a lot of people and
uh just that in a random
you know one random day i would just go
out and it doesn't matter you're let me
give you a hint it doesn't matter how
old you are
from for me to be able to just
you know
take you out so yeah okay that's pretty
it's going to keep me on my toes
um for me i um
[Music]
i feel like
one of the
it's it's in the very
beginning moments of the
of the show but um chrissy my character
um quote-unquote becomes a woman and um
we we get to see that and um
you know i think what's really cool
about what fx has allowed us to explore
is like these female relationships and
female stories as well um
that
maybe we haven't always seen in
animation
um
adult animations so um
i
i'm really excited to just you know put
put that out there
um i'm really excited that my character
gets to do full frontal nudity in the
show um i don't think that's a spoiler
um but it's exciting for me because i
haven't done it in live action yet but i
got to kind of dip my toe in
uh with full frontal community yeah
that's exciting to me too thank you me
too thank you yeah seriously very
effective scenes all around though it's
it's used with great purpose i find it
to be a very powerful way to make happen
what happens in that moment it's gotta
happen i must let you go i'm gonna thank
you so much for your time today
congratulate you on your show big thanks
to everybody out there for watching this
video check out little demon on fx soon